[Music]
tumors that affect women
are mainly those that
involve purely female organs
therefore breast ovary uterus
cervix to date we have data that
tell us that at the level of the
European
Union women who die of cancer today are
about 600  thousand per year
clearly not all these numbers
concern exclusively female tumor specificities,
however, for example,
about 90 thousand women in Europe
die of breast cancer every year
the problem is that the scarcity of
economic resources also due to a long
period of crisis has meant that  the
free threshold for certain
diagnostic tests has been very high
an Italian family whose mother
wife periodically wants a
mammogram at least every
six months faces costs that are
around one thousand euros a year
not all families in Italy today
can afford to spend these
figures and what does it mean that
many women  and at risk they give up on
prevention
we are often not placed in the
economic geographical conditions of being able
to easily access these these
these treatments diagnoses these
diagnostic analyzes what happens in northern
europe where there is greater ease of
access to these it must also be possible to
take place  even for the most let's say
economically disadvantaged states because
social cohesion is needed also from
a health point of view
[Music]